un commerçant ambulance s'est arrêté
dans un village de la région de Herson
c'est tout de suite l'attroupement ici
on a vécu pendant des mois coupés du
monde sous le jou de l'armée russe
jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit repoussée
au-delà du fleuve d'hier
un peu de gras pour accompagner la soupe
les visages sont marqués par le froid
mais même sans électricité parfois
depuis près d'un an l’hiver mordant est
plus facile à supporter que le souvenir
de l'occupation russe
ils ont mis la vie des gens sans dessus
dessous ils ont arraché les toits qu'ils
avaient sur la tête les gens ont peur de
les voir revenir c'est le plus important
pour nous c'est plus important que
d'avoir de l'électricité on peut enfin
respirer librement on espère qu'on ne
reverra pas ces monstres dans les
parages pendant 300 ans
on souffre on ne vit pas si vous avez du
bois pour vous chauffer ça va pendant
des mois j'en avais pas alors je
rajoutais deux couvertures et je
m'endormais comme ça
on croise peu d'hommes par ici la
campagne de recrutement bat son plein
dans le pays difficile d'échapper à
l'appel des drapeaux il n'y a plus grand
monde pour travailler les champs de
toute façon inexploitable à cause des
mines
j'ai demandé au démineur d'intervenir
ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient trop
occupés et qu'ils ne pourraient pas
intervenir sur mon champ avant l'automne
prochain
les habitants reviennent peu à peu dans
la région de Kerson ceux qui n'ont pas
fui les combats reste traumatisés par
l'occupation russe dans les villages on
croise surtout des personnes âgées
parfois isolées à quelques exceptions
près
on est là depuis le début nous avons
tout traversé les explosions qui
illuminent le ciel on les voyait à
travers la fenêtre
Ilona jeune veuve a refusé de partir et
d'abandonner sa mère tout son argent
sert à chauffer la seule pièce habitable
de la maison qu'elle partage avec sa
fille est née et ses jumeaux de 5 mois
voleodymir et Varvara n'est sous
l'Occupation
lorsqu'ils sont nés il n'y avait pas
d'électricité
il y a j'ai entendu une énorme explosion
j'ai couru vers eux en me disant si l'un
d'entre nous meurt
autant mourir tous ensemble
sans souffrir
[Musique]
les villages de la région de Herson
reprennent vie doucement ceux qui comme
Ilona ont vécu l'occupation savourent la
liberté retrouvée mais tous ici savent
que si les rues sont reculés ils ne sont
pas loin toujours menaçants